[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un passionné de sport local
au programme aujourd'hui comme toujours
des analyses et des débats sur
l'actualité sportive pour m'accompagner
nos chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau et oui ça fait du bien de se
retrouver présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite qui se remet au
score depuis début janvier on suit avec
attention ses progrès à chaque émission
en dehors de ça il est passionné à deux
cyclistes le de voile et de roller le
capitaine yann dujarrier du club de
vélizy 78 avec nous pendant une heure
comment allez-vous yable grande forme
les three sides et récits sans le
masquer ouais non non ça fait ça fait
grand plaisir merci michael et on espère
que les conditions vont encore
s'améliorer
les entraînement de musculation du coup
ça donne ça qui les satisfasse à pied je
suis allé courir ce matin là
tranquillement une petite demi-heure
tout va bien ça progresse on continue
notre tour de table à gauche musique
c'est une légende de ce talk eux c'est
le michael jordan de la répartie le
zinedine zidane des débats ici on l'a
baptisé l'italian lover des grilles
canal et journaliste chez tv 78 nous
fait l'honneur de venir une nouvelle
fois sur ce plateau bonjour grégory
c'est moi qui ait l'honneur de faire
partie de cette 7e bonjour mutuellement
julian bonjour à tous michael jordan
zinedine zidane on peut vous comparer à
ces légendes du sport jantes si l'on y
est utilisée aussi le nom de gianluigi
bouffonne j'aurais été encore plus
touchés parce que l'italienne lovers est
avant tout fan de football italien bien
sûr donc grand plaisir de retrouver la
team un plateau en plus en cette journée
de réouverture des boîtes de nuit c'est
la fête partout oui il n'y a pas de
coïncidence un réouverture des boîtes de
nuit en ouvre le plateau à tout le monde
on continue à ma droite me il est très
sportifs et amateurs des boîtes de nuit
également il adore sortir les biceps
quand il le faut lui aussi un expert
dans tous les sports nous vient tout
droit de versailles on le surnomme le
gladiateur pierre chevallier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
formé bonheur et amis quant à l'avenir
de vous revoir en vrai sans masse
presque comme avant donc ouais pleine
forme et très très heureux de de
toujours trouver en chair et en os on
croise les doigts en tout cas par
rapport à l'abri militaire comme ça va
ça va continuer à s'améliorer mais ça ne
sera plus qu'un mauvais souvenir et
comment vous allez fêter sa boîte de
nuit ce soir du courage pour les boîtes
pas chaque la joaillerie sienne peut
être inondées des bons vins bon vin et
cigare paf allez on y va enfin termine
en toute modération effectivement enfin
on termine à ma gauche musique vous
entendez sa musique c'est peut-être le
meilleur d'entre nous il est arrivé avec
sa bonne humeur et sa tchatche sur ce
plateau coach jaunisse ex-entraîneur du
plaisir rugby club est avec nous comment
allez-vous genre en plein format je
rejoins mes camarades en disant que
j'avais fait bien plaisir qu'on se
retrouve tous autour de la table pacha
club pour vous ce soir du coup non non
je suis bouche un peu commun comme
pierre je suis plus je suis plus bonne
petite bouteille de vin alors ici que
boîte de nuit où il ya tout le monde et
puis vous faire avec modération
génération et puis faut faire attention
quand même un sport parce qu'on a pu le
masque souvent rester prudent
le message est passé alors avant de
passer au programme de l'émission
commence tout de suite par du football
le paris saint germain qui s'entraînent
ici dans les yvelines au camp des loges
à saint germain en laye a réussi à
battre le real madrid en 8e de finale
aller de la ligue des champions parc des
princes les parisiens l'ont emporté 1 0
à la dernière seconde grâce un but de
l'inévitable killian mba p ils sont donc
en bonne position pour l'emporter la
question sur cette thématique le psg
va-t-il se qualifier oui ou non vous
votez
grégory sitcoms comme souvent sur les
pronostics alors
oui pour tout le monde et surtout oui
pour grégory les trois minutes addition
ça commence alors qu'à gori alors vous
êtes vous avez quand même mis un petit
peu de temps vous décider parce que je
pense sincèrement après je veux pas
porter la guigne au parisien que le
paris saint germain au vu de ce qui a
été montré hier là on enregistre
l'émission le match s'est déroulé hier
c'est la prestation la plus aboutie pour
moi pour le paris saint germain il ya un
vrai duel tactique même qui a été
remportée je pense par mauricio
pochettino face à un grand la matière
c'est carlo ancelotti pour pour le site
et un matériel à un match plein un
italien avec beaucoup de joueurs qui ont
été au niveau le seul et c'est peut-être
inquiétant on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler c'est lionel messi je trouve
avec andré le di maria donc c'est les
deux argentins hier qu'ils étaient pas
forcément dans le match mais s'il
fallait cibler quelqu'un à lionel messi
et que dire de la prestation de quillan
bape et une prestation majuscule avec
celle aussi de marco verra ticket est
indispensable au milieu terrain donc je
pense que le psg au vu de ce qu'il a
montré hier face au real madrid le real
madrid n'a pas montré grand chose va se
qualifier après est ce que c'est une
condition automatique est ce que cette
victoire est une condition automatique
pour une qualification des parisiens ça
rien n'est moins sûr parce qu'on sait
que le paris saint germain par le passé
face au barça face à manchester united
appuyez sur eu à subir quelques remonte
à la donc je pense que le psg va se
qualifier après c'est pas automatique
pour autant ils ont fait entrer le mot
remonte à da dans le dictionnaire
français le psg un
joaillier penser de cette manifestation
alors moi j'ai envie qu'ils allaient
victoire pour vous oui je pense qu'il
veut ce qualification voilà je pense
qu'il veut se qualifier alors pourquoi
parce que déjà il faut un bon match hier
soir connaître qu'il faut un beau match
mais c'est surtout que je suis pas été
celle du football mais j'ai un petit
real sait on est très loin du grand real
des chrétiens qui a remporté trois fois
la coupe d'europe des clubs champions on
est très très loin s'ils n'ont pas joué
ils ont quasiment ils ont rien fait ils
ont attendu les parisiens n'ont
abandonné on croyait presque c'était
attaque défense il y avait il n'y avait
rien moi moi j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé un
je traiterai pas la très très pauvre du
real donc je vois pas à la vue du match
alors est-ce qu'ils ont caché leur jeu
wii est celle stratégique selon vous
alors stratégique à ce niveau là
ils sont ici ce qu'aime excusez moi du
peu mais ils sont bien bien on est bien
d'accord donc parce que là à ce niveau
là une stratégie comme ça au psg avec
les stars qu'on leur connaît dire allez
on meurt on va jouer on va jouer un
petit peu la défense et attendre le
match à la maison
non je ne le pense pas je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas sachant qu'ils aimeraient
qu'il faut préciser où il ya vu le but à
l'extérieur si l'homme dit ouais super
surtout les dragues que je voulais
rebondir sur déjà deux points le premier
tactique depuis la disparition du but à
l'extérieur comptent double j'ai
l'impression que la tactiquement ils ont
joué pour pas comprendre series ils ont
en gros ils ont été plutôt resserré en
défaut recommencer à zéro au match
retour beaucoup dernier voilà pas
beaucoup de d'animation offensive
énormément défensive et au milieu de
terrain où on a eu un benzema qui était
qui était fantomatique peut-être pas en
forme parce qu'il revient on sait qui
revient à un petit peu de blessures mais
en tout cas à la pointe de l'attaqué
madrilène s'étaient c'était zéro pointé
donc ils ont eu aujourd'hui j'ai eu
l'impression qu'il jouait pour ne pas
prendre de but et pour pour 1,00 par
exemple le deuxième point moi qui me
fait dire qu'il est que le psg veut va
pouvoir se qualifier c'est que j'ai
l'impression enfin qu'ils vont être là
pour les grands rendez vous là on avait
quasiment tout le monde dans des états
de forme un peu différent on a un et
marc est revenue
le blondinet et on a surtout un kiki
bape et qui tient la baraque depuis le
début de la saison il l'a montré il l'a
montré sur les peut-être existé 20
derniers matches du psg en gros sur
toutes compétitions confondues et on a
laissé le psg contre rennes un petit peu
moribond est vraiment inquiétant dans
son organisation offensive etc etc une
victoire à la pyrrhus à la fin avec un
but déjà de 2 kg dames ap et là sur ce
match là ils ont haussé à la fois l'envi
la technique la stratégie effectivement
d'accord avec greg sur le sur l'aspect
stratégique et pour le coup 1 0 c'est
presque c'est presque peut payer par
rapport à par rapport à la gestion du
match au lierre vaut à vue il a eu une
grande et belle équipe du psg dans un
parc plein ça aussi ça fait du bien à
voir il ya énormément de jeux originaux
courtois pour les canaux trois ans mais
mise à part un tir mal son pénalty aussi
possible aux importants du poste parce
que parce que tout a été dit il parce
que tout simplement feint la seule chose
qu on pourrait rajouter c'est en effet
ce dire le niveau de jeu du psg sur les
trois prochaines semaines peut encore
augmenter puisque avec le retour de
neymar est une forme qui devrait être
ascendante bon ça peut ça peut ça peut
donner ça peut donner un peu mieux sur
le match retour ce qui est sûr c'est que
il faudra juste être un poil plus
réaliste sur le match retour et on sait
qu'ils sont capables de marquer à
l'extérieur sans aucun problème moi je
vois les genevois ne les vois pas je les
vois pas je doive à perdre et surtout
avec comme disait jean la qualité du du
real de madrid qui est quand même très
moribonde très inquiétant autant à la
sortie du week end les deux clubs leurs
prestations en championnat et est
inquiétante on s'est aperçu marie hier
soir que le psg avait été capable de de
relever le niveau et de rentrer dans une
vraie ligue des champions donc pour vous
c'est sûr à 100% que le psg sera en
quarts de finale avec des gens que l'on
n'est jamais sûr à 100% il ya trois
semaines qui vont c'est qu'ils vont qui
vont qui vont passer il peut y avoir
plein de blessures chez les uns comme
chez les autres il ya plein de
paramètres maintenant on fera le on en
reparlera juste juste avant bien sûr les
gens aient un plus le real va jouer sa
de ces deux états tout à fait ils ont
pris les cartons jaunes il y avait des
micros et fernand mendy aussi qui joue
qui ne joueront pas le match retour à 0
kg mais on sait toute l'importance du
brésilien dans le terrain avec notre
public tony goose l'équipe et après non
mais le paramètre important et il ya le
soulevèrent à prendre en compte c'est
aussi ce délai il ya trois semaines qui
vont passer on sait que bas par le passé
ça a pu aussi faire cogiter les
parisiens donc on espère qu'il n'y aura
pas les scénarios qu'on a pu connaître
des scénarios catastrophiques et ça sera
au bernabéu aussi il y aura le public
que la leur ils aiment ça fait c'est
pareil ce match là ça fait pas trois
semaines qu'ils attendent ils ça fait
deux mois et demi depuis le début de sa
fait 2 mois et demi depuis le tirage au
sort qu'ont et mine de rien avant
c'était souvent des matchs qu'on
rencontre à partir des quarts de finale
ont rencontré passé gros en huitièmes de
finale là on peut se dire que oui ils
ont passé la phase très longue
d'attentes pour le rencontrer et en
effet ils ont été capables d'élever le
niveau de jeu juste pour ce match voilà
donc en effet ils sont capables
aujourd'hui de d'être au niveau de la
ligue des champions donc juste pour
terminer sur cette thématique grigori
vous êtes sûr à 100% que le faire parce
qu'elle est fière regarder 1% pour les
raisons que vous
je vous ai exposé tout à l'heure il ya
eu il
ya des antécédents pour le paris saint
germain et encore une fois je le remet
sur la table mais moi je suis très
inquiet du niveau de jeu de lionel messi
alors oui 1 1 qui elle bat p
stratosphérique mais depuis le début de
la saison la pulga elle est transparente
dans ce psg et franchement c'est
inquiétant alors le prochain match se
jouera donc le 9 mars prochain à 21h au
stade santiago à bernabéu nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de cyclisme sur piste avec le
retour aux affaires de grégory baugé
dans le staff de l'équipe de france
coup de projecteur également sur tony
hawk eye sportif yves binois combattra
le 14 mai prochain face à bah collet
mais avant de développer ce thème on va
parler de la coupe de france de football
et de la qualification historique du fc
versailles 78 en demi finale de la coupe
de france
[Musique]
ils l'ont fait le fc versailles 78 s'est
brillamment qualifié pour les demi
finales de la coupe de france en
s'imposant ce mercredi 9 février face à
bergerac à périgueux pourtant rien n'a
été simple pour le club yvelinois tout
avait bien commencé
les joueurs de la cité royale ouvre le
score à la 14e minute par inzaghi
diarrassouba magnifique but pour un
joueur qui n'a pas souvent l'occasion de
s'illustrer dans l'exercice 1 0 ce sera
le score à la pause mais les joueurs de
versailles se font peur et se font
égalisé à la 90e minute par bergerac un
but signé avec celle très sens à ce
moment là on s'est dit que ce serait
très compliqué d'aller chercher la
victoire est finalement les versailles
et à l'emportent 5 tirs au but à 4 dans
l'euphorie générale après un tir au but
manqué par mingoua on écoute la réaction
du coach à la fin de cette rencontre
historique c'est un match difficile face
à une bonne équipe avec un socle solide
défensif on a réussi à déjouer ce plan
en marquant assez tôt
ça reste un avantage très important face
à ce genre d'équipé mais on a manqué
justement de lucidité sur une situation
pour pouvoir tenir le score jusqu'au
bout le bon derrière les garçons ont
réussi à se concentrer et s'approprier
cette séance de pénalties dès que le
match et l'infini on a pris un but mais
il ya quatre minutes ou plus on savait
sinon c'est une possibilité on est parti
en confiance tout mon ami c'est penalty
on a la chance que un genre de bergerac
tir sur le poteau mais ça nous assurait
aujourd'hui donc très content bravo
encore au fc versailles 78 g unit que
vous êtes tous à gontaud autour de la
table absolument pas ça fait des années
qu'on me demande quel club yvelinois
fasse un beau parcours en coupe de
france bien sûr on ne reverra plus de
notre vie ont peut-être on ne sait pas
c'est la première fois d'ici à
versailles a un beau projet on n'est pas
l'abri qui puisse reconnaître commettent
ce genre d'exploit par la nuit pierre
vous êtes très bon tour et je suis je
suis chauvin je suis je suis localement
localement
mais localement enthousiaste évidemment
tout ce que ça tout ce que ça apporte au
football d'abord rendre à césar ce qui
est ce qui est à césar mais au sport en
général à versailles ville culturelle
ville historique on l'a déjà dit plein
de fois mais là il ya des équipes il ya
des équipes qui tirent leur épingle du
jeu le football le rugby bien évidemment
et d'autres et d'autres équipes comme le
basket d'ailleurs aussi et on a on a
justement on a avec grâce à eux grâce
aux essais versailles 78 on a un petit
peu vaincu le signe indien qui aurait
tendance à dire que y'a pas de sportifs
ou ya pas de sport à versailles
accueilla que des théâtres il ya qu'un
château et autres et je trouve leur
performance en plus leur tour en tour de
france leur leur épopée en tour de
france absolument fraîche fraîche et
enthousiasmante et qui aussi je suis à
chaque fois épaté que je l'entends le
calme olympien de de youssef chebbi je
trouve que les autres c'est vers 13h10 à
s'élancer je le trouve dans son rôle je
le trouve dans son dans son projet et à
chacun et chaque tour passé on s'emballe
pas il est lucide et puis la lie layar
il ya un everest quart et en demi finale
et en demi finale demi-finale de coupe
de france magic genre magique et ans
j'écoutais
gtv c'est vrai c'est vrai bien sûr qu'on
est et coléreux qu'on est reclus vision
yvelinois en demi finale la coupe
d'offres ac c'est une grande première à
ce n'était jamais arrivé avant
amis du psg version beaucoup mieux psp
j'ai vraiment parlé juste après on va en
parler
pour l'histoire du terrain alors non
mais c'est très bien c'est magnifique
d'ailleurs je veux j'étais le seul à
avoir le bon pronostic
ramenant à césar ce qui est à césar donc
je n'ai jamais vu le passage aux tirs au
but les gringos riquet qu'est ce que
vous aviez dit oui bah moi j'avais mis
une victoire de bergerac je l'assumé en
plateau mais bon peut-être que ma
stratégie est de mettre l'équipe en face
pour voir versailles passé non mais
c'est incroyable c'est une épopée
incroyable pour versa et pour les
yvelines pour un club amateur c'était ma
première envolée sur ce plateau quand
j'ai rejoint cette cette belle équipe de
voir une une épopée un parcours
exceptionnel d'un club amateur en coupe
de france et tous les sens de cette
coupe de france c'est de voir des petits
allaient challenge et des gros et quelle
année exceptionnelle pour versailles on
l'espère qui se clôtura parce que là le
parcours exceptionnel qu'il y ait une
qualification une élimination en
demi-finale oui alors il arrive rempli
largement rempli il est largement rempli
parce que là il y aura un club de ligue
1 c'est vrai qu'au tour précédent on
aurait pu s'il y avait une élimination
de versailles le parcours a été
exceptionnelle mais si on était à 2 face
à un club de même niveau et donc il y
aurait eu moins de saveur forcément mais
là c'est ça peut être une année vraiment
exceptionnelle pour une demi finale de
coupe de france ils vont jouer leur
chance face à nice ils sont six ans très
bonne course pour être et bien promu la
saison prochaine en national il ya
toujours la question du terrain à
résoudre et ça ce sera je pense le le
principal dossier sur lequel il faudra
s'atteler et puis pour nous deux nickel
journalistes avec une préférence pour le
sport couvrant l'actualité des yvelines
avoir un club qui se hisse jusqu'en demi
finale c'est exceptionnel la question
sur cette thématique est ce que c'est
vraiment une surprise cette victoire de
versailles oui ou non
sur ce contre bergerac non
vous êtes partagés pierre pourquoi nous
partager parce que j'ai toujours pensé
que c'était le tour le plus difficile
qu'il était était donné à versailles de
jouer parce que c'est inique et de même
niveau national de nationale 2 tête de
leur poule où c'était un petit peu les
jumeaux ils avaient quand même pas et
sur l'aspect
j de la coupe de france en moins c'est
quand on se fade un gros on se
transcende on n'est pas attendu et on
peut créer la surprise là c'était deux
équipes de même acabit avec deux
techniciens qui peut-être se connaissent
ou ont joué à peu près les mêmes les
mêmes les mêmes paris et les mêmes et
sur les mêmes enjeux et donc
là ou là où oui je dirais que c'est une
surprise c'est que c'est que c'était pas
un tour facile malgré tout ça reste un
quart de finale de coupe de france mais
contre un adversaire de même niveau et
ensuite
moins surpris par ce que parce que
versailles et la hollande et vous cette
saison versailles au rendez vous à
chaque tour de coupe de france il ya eu
il ya eu des petits il ya eu des moyens
et a eu un gros toulouse en ligue 2 en
8e dont la voilà j'ai un peu partagé sur
sur l'enjeu du match sur l'écart et et
sur le parcours avant avant de faire ça
il mais après après ici ils sont à leur
place et puis c'est un périlleux ont
plus est à l'extérieur donc ça rajoute
et une difficulté pour versailles ça
c'est un joujou homologué normalement à
la base qui a été homologuée aux dalits
moment qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
la victoire logique
djoko aurait pu tuer le match il ne rien
il a raté deux res de claix il a raté
ses deux vraies occasions mal même de
cause hier il a raté deux vraies
occasions et en effet il le match aurait
pu être plié au milieu de la deuxième mi
temps sans aucun problème il aurait pu
très largement avoir 2 0 et être
complètement à l'abri c'est juste s'y
retrouve deux fois seul face au but 6
face au gardien en première mi temps
c'est c c'est là où il aurait plus
qu'entre habitants contre nice il faudra
pas rater ces occasions ils les auront
c'est sûr et certain ils ont ils en
auront pas des tonnes il faudra pas les
rater outil un petit peu sur sur nismo
tout à leur habitude jeudi contre
l'incendié
alors on va revenir tout sur ce but
marqué par inzaghi diarrassouba le
médecin qui ne marque presque jamais on
l'écouté aux débris feu juste après
le match il a fini jeudi le real on a
pris un but mais il ya 90 minutes ou
plus on savait
déjà qu on ne nie pas polluer la passe
me dit bon on est vraiment ce soir dans
un match de coupe pour une place en demi
finale maintenant voilà avec la magie de
la coupe sûrement
peut-être qu'elle va rentrer et j'ai la
chance en fait un rebond qui surprend le
gardien et à ce moment là j'y croyais
même toit en fait mais angers marqué
depuis trois ans maintenant et d'un coup
je me suis dit non mais je pense qu'elle
est rentrée je crois et c'est là que les
jeux commencent à mettre un coup de
poing dans le vide tellement je savais
pas quoi faire comme célébration parce
que j'ai fait ainsi démarqué
franchement
c'est en tout cas c'est un travail
collectif de l'équipe tout ça oui je
tiens à souligner
il remercie nos supporters et l'équipe
parce que c'est un travail collectif
j'étais persuadé que c'était un effet du
ballon ils n'ont pas et non pas un faux
rebond parce que en effet on voit bien
qu'elle ne part pas dans l'axé du but et
qui leur revient au moment où elle passe
devant le gardien et je pensais plus à
un effet donné à la balle brossée voilà
plutôt qu'à un mois il est honnête
et le plus trompeur pour jouer en tant
que garde un côté un peu ce niveau les
petites phrases comme ça avec le rebond
juste avant juste avant de faire l'arrêt
c'est les tirs les plus difficiles à
arrêter et la trajectoire a été bonne
alors oui parce qu'étant que si vous
jouez face à des grecs à d'année vous
affrontez
non mais frappe avec rebond où tous les
gardiens vous diront que c'est les plus
difficiles à sortir et alors ce qui est
drôle et il est très honnête aussi sur
le côté ne s'attendait pas à marquer
c'est que même dans la célébration il a
pas su quoi faire sur le moment il était
plus surpris et non mais c'est
magnifique en tout cas qu'on a vu face à
bergerac genre qu'est ce que vous en
pensez cette célébration ce but non mais
c'est bien parce que l'humain mélodies
il sait même pas qu'il avait marqué
pressé il tenait et marqué seulement une
fois en championnat cette année
deux buts
c'est quand la réussite ça fait partie
la chasse a fait partie de la réussite
mais regardez regardez ces joueurs là à
d'autres niveaux et ses joueurs qui ne
marque jamais qui marque dans les
grandes occasions ça rajoute un petit
peu plus à l'épopée versaillaise le
lilian thuram 1/2 finale 98 que nous en
forme deux qui partent jamais tout ça
ces deux autres
autres niveaux autre temps et ça prouve
en tout cas que qui sont tous concernés
il joue et il le dit il tente sa chance
c'est un match de coupe d'asie frappe et
bim tendre et est finalement et c'est un
but décisif parce qu'il marque tôt et
que et que ça finit à 1 partout donc
c'est étonnant étant alors avant de
passer à la prochaine thématique vous
propose de regarder une dernière fois
ses images de joie et on revient ici
juste derrière
on commence à connaître par coeur ce
champ à pierre chevalier on l'a on leur
pique un petit peu aussi au ballon ovale
on a repiqué un petit peu parce que
c'est monsieur alors on a reçu sociaux
apparemment ça vient du rc lens se
change et ont ils ont demandé à
copyright c'est en tout sur ce genre
c'est je pense que c'est ça exprime bien
la joie le la solidarité un petit peu de
sang fair-play parce qu' aimer mais ces
gentilles écossais reste sa chambre mais
reste dans les esprits le faire
pleinement des mots bien plus vulgaire
danser dans ces chansons là où dans ces
moments là non mais ce que j côté c'est
important de le préciser le fair play
alors entre les joueurs il ya eu du fair
play pendant la rencontre même si c'est
l'attaquant sait qui m'échappe qui a été
expulsé ibrahim bahit christopher iba iq
a été expulsé en fait qui voilà qui
étaient rentrés a pas longtemps qu'ils
découpent littéralement le genre de
bergerac mais ya pas eu forcément de
fair play entre les dirigeants il ya où
on va pas forcément relater ici en
plateau mais même le directeur général
de bergerat qui a dit en interview
d'après match que ce n'était pas une
bonne publicité pour le foot amateur ce
n'est pas le plus beau projet qui allait
en demi finale donc ça on peut le
regretter moi ce que je voulais juste
ajouter le sport c'est que versailles a
été très solide sur la rencontre c'est
vrai qu'il ya cette qualification alors
qu' une surprise ou pas moi je pense que
ce n'est pas une surprise parce que les
versaillais ont été ont été solides il
avait montré sur les tours précédents
notamment face à toulouse c'est une
rencontre où quand même dans la
domination c'est plus bergerac a eu le
ballon il ya une sous x 63 % une semble
de possession pour pour bergerac c'est
une domination qui a été stérile parce
qu'au final ils font un seul tir cadré
c'est le sait le but
est de l'autre côté un versailles très
solide que j'ai trouvé n'aurait
d'ailleurs en défense 1 mène durant de
jeu vinet qui avait le brassard de
capitaine très solide qui savait gérer
les les attaques les attaques de
bergerac des périgourdins et ils ont
montré de la solidité et de la solidité
aussi dans la tête parce qu'après avoir
pris ce but égalisateur dans les tous
derniers moments on pensait qu'ils
allaient s'écrouler et au final ils
arrivent à se qualifier aux tirs au but
et ça c'est magnifique
aussi dans le déroulé du match il ya eu
moins de moins de fautes des moins de
cartons donc plus de maîtrise en car que
que caen 8e en huitièmes et deux rouges
de rouge et 7 jaunes je crois d de
chaque côté en tout mais donc ça prouve
aussi une peut-être une homogénéité de
niveau et une maîtrise peu de parts et
d'autres d'ailleurs deux des faits de
jeu on va passer maintenant notre
prochaine thématique on va passer à
l'envolée de grégory le moment fort de
cette émission de quoi allez vous nous
parler grégory scie de mon immense
déception après toulouse après bergerac
à périgueux versailles jouera pour la
troisième fois de suite à l'extérieur
les yvelinois devront disputer leur
place en finale de la coupe de france à
900 km de la cité royale dans l'antre de
l'ogcnice l'alliance rivera la fête
s'annonçait pourtant grande car
versailles devait bien recevoir la
rencontre à l'origine une région entière
derrière le dernier représentant
franciliens dans la compétition le monde
amateur porter en demi finale mais
aucune solution n'a été trouvée pas
possible stade mont boron nono homologué
pour un match de cette ampleur le fcv 78
à sonder le parc des princes refus du
psg j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure le
stade charléty refus du préfet de police
en raison de la sécurité c'est dans
cette enceinte qui avait éclaté les
échauffourées entre les supporters et du
paris fc et de lyon enfin trop cher le
stade de france pour les frais
d'organisation chiffré minimum à 250
milles euros même si des solutions
lastminute com tours le mans ou même 3
et lens ont été évoqués le mal était
déjà fait à mon sens la magie de la
coupe de france s'est évaporé l'essence
même de ce trophée chante simon c'est de
permettre justement à des petits de
rêver de réaliser des gros parcours des
parcours incroyable d'aller se frotter à
des gros et des clubs professionnels
n'y avait-il pas moyen de trouver des
solutions en concertation avec la
fédération française de football
l'organisateur du tournoi les autorités
les collectivités de trouver une
solution dans ce moment historique
rappelant que ce n'est que la cinquième
fois dans l'histoire qu'un club de
quatrième division atteint les demi
finales et ce n'est pas rien et bien non
le club a tout fait mais la rencontre a
été inversée se décidera à nice derrière
les joueurs les supporters sont bien
sûrs les premières victimes de cette
décision que de cette indécision ils ont
été fidèles pourtant dans les
déplacements à toulouse à périgueux on a
la chance et d'y avoir participé tous
les deux nickel ils ont été aussi au
rendez vous place du marché à versailles
haut il y avait la retransmission sur
écran géant de la rencontre mais là ce
sera compliqué d'organiser un tel
déplacement à nice en aussi peu de temps
la fed se retrouve quelque peu gâchée il
rêvait nous rêvions tous d'une demi
finale dans l'enceinte du parc des
princes pourquoi pas finalement le paris
saint germain a éliminé versailles et le
représentant de la région ile de france
de la compétition et pour une fois qu'on
parle du football francilien sans parler
du psg pourquoi s'en priver le fc
versailles a tout de suite évoqué cette
possibilité
ils ont sondé cette possibilité regarder
ce tweet qui était assez drôle coucou
paris saint-germain tu as de la place au
parc des princes début mars c'est pour
des amis interpellés le club de manière
assez drôle sur twitter la date initiale
du 1er mars était libre au niveau du
calendrier mais le paris saint germain a
refusé car le club et dont engager des
travaux d'entretien de sa pelouse déjà
repoussée après france kazakhstan en
novembre beaucoup de matches prévus
aussi dans l'enceinte entre la ligue 1
et l'équipe féminine mais j'ai une
question le psg ne s'était-il pas
autoproclamés défenseurs du football
populaire face aux autres équipes
voulant créé il ya un an la super league
il n'y a qu'à regarder la déclaration
d'après-match du président du paris
saint-germain nasser el rey la hi-fi
juste après psg real c'était donc hier
il n'a pas hésité à tacler une nouvelle
fois le club madrilène qui était à
l'origine du projet super league je
crois en un football accessible à tous
du petit club au plus gros clubs
vraiment chara ne pas permettre
justement à versailles de venir jouer
dans son stade me fait quand même douté
de la sincérité de cette déclaration
bref passons il ne reste plus qu'une
seule solution pour voir et bien un
prochain match de versailles dans la
région francilienne c'est celui cette
solution c'est celle de battre nice et
d'aller en finale qu'il a c'est sûr se
tiendra au stade de france allez
versailles bien sûr votre avis sur cette
envolée vous voulez réagir qui veut
commencer yann peut-être je trouve ça
honteux voilà qu'en plus les raisons
donnée par le psg ne valent pas ils ont
des travaux c'est ce qu'ils ont dit oui
non mais ça vaut pas de danse à venir
faut arrêter c'est ridicule du nez
travaux il aurait pu les faire bien
avant et en plus
le psg normalement il devrait être en
demi finale de coupe de france donc le
stade n'était pas disponible pour faire
les travaux à ce moment là donc faut
enfin voila je ne trouve pas ça cohérent
et j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
incohérences pierre triste dommage pour
plein de raisons qu'on a commencé à
évoquer ici il y avait effectivement un
vrai une vraie volonté de la mairie de
versailles de trouver une solution
francilienne il y avait même en
imaginant le stade de créteil par
exemple mais qui n'était pas forcément
homologué à ce stade là de la
compétition donc les stades que les
stades que greg a assité pas trop de
choix dans la date à ce moment là mais
mais quand même des stades des stades et
des possibilités à droite à gauche
digne de ce nom et pour le coup que le
parc refuse que psg refuse pour un pour
un tour de francs un tour de coupe de
france qui aura réuni peut-être six
avaient terni de france peut-être
c'était dix mille 15000 personnes je
pense pas tellement plus les supporters
niçois pas forcément fait le déplacement
mais on gagne à nouveau le tirage au
sort et c'est nous qui recevons est pour
pour des pour des problèmes structurels
dont greg a déjà parlé on a en ahl on a
la malchance de ne pas pouvoir se réunir
et et pousser derrière notre équipe on a
vu qu'il y avait un vrai engouement
c'est là que c'est inhabituel à
versailles je vous le concède c'est
inhabituel mais justement ce cette
épopée tellement magique que
d'après en gros ça emmène les faits de
s'armer de les foules dont il y avait la
place du marché il y aurait pu avoir un
stade y aurait pu avoir 2000 3000 5000
peut-être 6000 spectateurs si ça avait
été si ça avait été proche là le choix
de
non choix de charléty c'est là on prend
on prend plein fouet les conséquences
des événements de paris fc d'après nos
informations dès qu'ils ont proposés
charléty dès qu'ils ont composée ça à la
mairie de paris la préfecture ils ont
l'élégance est aussi
là pour le coup pour rester dans le
cliché je ne pense pas qu'on ait des
hooligans totalement non maîtrisables en
l'occurrence la restons restons dans la
sportivité dans l'oeil dans le cliché où
ce soir et je pense que ça s'est très
bien passé mais mais voilà donc très
déçu très déçu pour l'ensemble des
supporters les anciens comme les
nouveaux parce qu'il y en a des nouveaux
là maintenant et on ne peut pas aller au
bout et donc l âge mais je me vis dans
la roue de grégory en dix ans maintenant
maintenant c'est au rendez vous au stade
de france mais est-ce que ça va pas
jouer finalement sur sur les
performances des versaillais parce
qu'ils vont aller affronter le troisième
de ligue 1 à l'extérieur là on peut dire
c'est quasiment un miracle si
passionnant et moi je jouais juste qu'un
avant de répondre à votre question
d'hier se plaindre pour moi c'est un
scandale c'est un scandale parce que là
on avait la possibilité de montrer les
belle image du football une très belle
image à travers le parcours sportif de
versailles le psg avait l'occasion aussi
de redorer son blason autrement que
d'enfants gâtés où on ne parle que d'eux
est constamment il avait la possibilité
non pas de faire des grandes phrases
mais de montrer que c'était pas que les
phrases et de tendre la main un club
amateur soi-disant eux le font ils le
ils n'attendent que ça ils ne l'ont pas
fait ils ont eu la chance de le faire
ils ne l'ont pas fait même le préfet le
trio charléty comme dit pierre c'est par
les hooligans kilos est mort à
versailles qui vont mettre le feu à
charléty tout ça tout le monde se
trouvent des excuses alors qu'on avait
un beau projet sportif et qu'on avait
une belle équipe qui représentait la
région ile de france et qui avaient la
possibilité de défendre ses couleurs à
domicile et bien tout le monde lui
fermant la porte jeudi tout le monde
tout le monde parce que là tout ça ce
sont des excuses à deux balles entre le
jardinier du psg et
les jeunes aux violences de charléty
mais s'aimer mais c'est la rigolade et
même la fédération la ligue et la
fédération
ils ont guéri qu'ils ont bien au dernier
moment avait le sens de pénurie des baux
longue et il obtient homologué pour
l'arago drôle pourquoi ça c'est patricia
l'île de france pourquoi là bas prix
créteil à ce moment là dans un même
souffle aussi mais pourquoi l'avoir
créteil bonne bouffe et que de la même
manière qu'on l'a fait pour périgueux
pourquoi ne l'a pas fait nous pourquoi
ne l'a pas fait tout le monde à tourner
le dos à cette équipe à ce beau parcours
alors effectivement pour répondre à
votre question maintenant c'est que
effectivement et bien les joueurs
peuvent apprendre un grand coup derrière
les étiquettes et j'espère parce que
pierre le disais tout à l'heure bon
apparemment ils sont validés ils ont
validé ce choix quand même et sa valise
pour le joueur
c'est pas
dans le sens de gens finalement les
seuls clubs qui ont proposé au paris
saint germain au paris saint germain à
versailles le lapsus révélateur de les
accueillir c'est des clubs hors région
francilienne on parle de clubs comme
tours le mans il ya eu aussi trois et
lens qui ont proposé à versailles de
venir jouer dans leur antre finalement
cette solution a été écartée donc ça ça
va dans son sens en disant que et après
ça il fallait remplir les stades à deux
trois heures de route aussi c'est pas la
même chose que si on va au bout
de trois ans de route vous avez quand la
possibilité de drainer les les
supporters versailles et que la à nice
qui va y aller allons y rivas y aura
très peu de tout le monde je veux juste
je finis pour une fois que je peux je
parle peu monsieur yann c'est que je
tout à l'heure bien 10 et la sérénité de
la grenade versailles et j'espère qu'il
aura cette sérénité pour justement faire
2-2 de 2,7
j'allais dire j'ai à dire un vilain mot
de de toute cette bande igal sait qu'il
peut y avoir autour du club de
versailles une force pour ses joueurs
une force même si le match paraît sur le
papier très difficile voire très
difficile sur le papier du coup cette
rencontre forcément si on est le plus
réaliste possible
oui
nice est bien supérieur à versailles
troisième de ligue 1 maintenant la coupe
de france crédit assez ici est aussi
belle parce qu'il y à des exploits qui
sont réalisées on a vu des clubs cette
saison des clubs amateurs sortir à des
clubs de ligue 1 c'était le cas de
bergerac il avait sorti ses missiles
alors à domicile c'était pas forcément
les mêmes situations mais nice faut voir
aussi que cette saison alors oui c'est
le troisième de ligue 1 c'est un club
qui est très solide on l'a vu sur le
tour précédent et même les deux tours
précédents ils sortent tour à tour
marseille et ils ont sorti le paris
saint-germain juste juste avant mais
face au petit club de ligue 1 ils sont
cassés les dents cette saison il ya le
résultat très récent et cette défaite
contre clermont il aussi perdu contre
metz donc c'est la preuve que toute la
petite équipe de lui aussi la venue de
l'équipe document voilà mais c'est la
preuve que face à des petites équipes
sur le papier ils peuvent se relâcher
pourquoi pas prendre le match à la
légère et se faire surprendre par
l'équipe versaillais c'est tout ce qu'on
peut souhaiter à ce que c'est vraiment
dans le style de christophe galtier de
prendre les matches à la légère le coach
niçois
aujourd'hui nice fait figure d'ultra
favorite de cette compétition
quand on regarde les équipes qui restent
en lice voilà et en plus bas par rapport
au parcours le fait d'avoir battu
marseille d'avoir le deuxième de ligue 1
d'avoir battue bleue meleder de lignan
sur le parcours en effet c'est ma miss
fait qu'il devienne le favori
incontestable maintenant c'est
maintenance c'est la magie de la coupe
de vin match c'est un match
et djoko ratera peut-être pas l'occasion
qu'il aura sur le match c'est tout ce
que je leur souhaite parce qu'ils en ont
certainement pas 50 je vais redire la
même chose que tout à l'heure et et puis
après ben donc c'est que marseille est
solide versailles est solide
défensivement
voilà ils ont sincèrement dans les deux
matches qu'on a vue dernièrement parce
que c'est les mettre hors d télévisée
d'y jouer dans un fauteuil ils sont ils
sont propres ils sont propre
défensivement moi je vois là on peut on
peut que leur souhaiter de dalé d'aller
au stade de france hier chevalier s'est
rapidement et si c'est bon parce qu'ils
ont créé christophe galtier que qui
peuvent justement à espérer aller au
bout sont pas sûrs d'eux en championnat
de pouvoir les titiller le psg jusqu'au
bout où ils vont peut-être aller
chercher la deuxième place
en bisbille avec marseille mais ce
technicien et leur atout principal est
la nouvelle c'est qu'ils récupéreront
christopher et bailly qui aura purgé son
match de suspension sur la compétition
stationnaire thon rouge c'était vrai
pétition est géré par la fédération
française de football les joueurs
peuvent purger sur le championnat ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle on va
maintenant passer à notre prochaine
thématique sur l'engouement populaire
observé à verser pendant cette épopée en
coupe de france jamais à part pour un
match de l'équipe de france de football
la place du marché à vercel avait été
aussi rempli plus de 1500 à personnes se
sont donné rendez vous pour assister à
ce match face à bergerac on écoute les
réactions à la fin du match
c'est une grande fierté d'avoir un club
qui fait un tel exploit
pour tous ces modules ces versets y
assister c'est magique les normes
alors il ya des boutiques aux couleurs
du fc versailles 78 tout le monde en
parle à versailles la question sur cette
thématique est ce que cet engouement est
vraiment surprenant à versailles quand
on voit ces images on voit les images du
but ses supporters qui est qu'ils se
déplacent est-ce que c'est surprenant
alors pour vous pierre oui oui pour vous
aux gens des grues aussi yann ont alors
fait un petit duel entre jean et yann
gens vont commencer peut-être jorian
moi j'ai mis gmi quoi oui
c'est très surprenant versailles oui
voilà oui c'est surprenant pourquoi mais
tout simplement parce que c'est
versailles et que versailles c'est quand
même pas les plus les plus les plus
rigolos
donc là pour moi voilà c'est tout
simplement parce que
c'est pas c'est pas la ville la plus
démonstrative
kata kata à la joie sportive et
si ce n'est au rugby le rugby c'est au
rugby il ya de l'engouement mais après
voilà c'est particulier est fait c'est
spécial pour moi par rapport à la ville
et à l'état d'esprit
mais non c'est pas étonnant parce que
parce que c'est le football et le
football
soulève des foules et voilà quand là
quand l'équipe de france est championne
du monde ou à des beaux matchs des beaux
résultats et bien tout le monde regarde
tout le monde a envie de sortir dans la
rue faire la fête et bien là versailles
on et versailles et on est fiers que
notre équipe de versailles et ses
résultats et du coup les gens sortent
dans la rue pour faire la même fait que
si cette équipe de france qui qui avait
qui avait brillé c'est c'est la force du
football je pense que c'est le seul
malheureusement c'est le seul sport qui
qui est capable de sortir les foules de
2,2 de chez soi et qui va mettre 7,7
cette ambiance et cet engouement dans le
dans le coeur des gens donc confirmé
je confirme plutôt gens parce que moi je
trouve ça surprenant pour l'histoire du
fcv 78 notamment si je reprends le un
déjà un tour prometteur en coupe de
france de versailles quand il avait
affronté le rc lens à mont boron il ya
trois ans ou quatre ans je crois en tout
cas de sa retraite en 2018 de mémoire
voilà et ils espéreront 4 à 2 il y avait
du monde à montbron mais grosso modo
dans la ville c'est comme si s'était
rien passé hélas avait été émise par les
ultras
exactement vous en souvenez par le curve
le collectif des ultras versailles et il
ya les ultras outils et et donc il n'y
avait pas eu cet engouement là
maintenant là on est quatre ans plus
tard il ya un projet qui se met en place
on le sait il y à il ya surtout ce tour
face à cette épopée magnifique en coupe
de france hélas la place du marché n'a
jamais été et n'a jamais été aussi
pleines et aussi aussi lumineuse
j'allais rester latéral de la coupe du
monde 2018 en vendée voir la france face
à la croatie donc partout partout en
france ça c'était c'est un événement
national et donc donc partout - fonds ou
là le football de l'équipe de france
tous les blés soulève les foules à
versailles oui c'est surprenant parce
que parce que c'est pas encore dans la
culture mais c'est surprenant mais
extrêmement prometteur et ses essais
c'est un sportif versailles et qui vous
le dit
la vraie surprise pour moi c'est la
place du marché c'est plus de 1000
personnes réunies une ambiance de dingue
nicolas landry notre image est qu'ils
étaient et fumigènes avec des supporters
qui étaient totalement euphorique juste
ensuite parce que finalement quand on
regarde le déplacement on a eu la chance
de suivre de l'intérieur le déplacement
des supporters verser 56 supporters le
bus qui était rempli donc on a senti
aussi un certain engouement maintenant
là où c'est surprenant c'est que nous
pour suivre le club de versailles sur
toute la saison le stade membres on est
rarement plein c'est pas un club qui
attire encore même au retour des joueurs
sur des exploits coupe de france face à
toulouse et la face à bergerac on était
au retour des joueurs à bergerac avec
une vingtaine de personnes pour
accueillir les joueurs c'est encore trop
peu on sent que l'engouement a pas pris
totalement mais voilà voilà la vraie
surprise il ya eu un engouement
ponctuelles indications sur ce match
serait surprise la place du marché et
même quand on va faire des micro
trottoir dans versailles c'est assez
rare de trouver des gens qui
s'intéressent
à cette thématique on nous a dit plutôt
à un moment donné que versailles c'était
plus une ville de rugby si on devait
parler de sport que de football voilà
donc pas je trouve ça en ce sens que
c'est surprenant de voir un tel
engouement
quand je vois les images et le
comportement des supporters de
versailles je comprends mieux pourquoi
la préfecture à
charles heidsieck parce que franchement
ça fait peur ça fait
je crois qu'ils les portent à taper sur
sur le bus de façon très violente
des images
comme on peut voir là ils m'ont encerclé
j'ai eu très très peur ça nous allait
faire mais pas trop justement vous
faites à la transition à grégory on va
regarder cet extrait à humoristique sur
les supporters versailles et et ont
débriefé juste après nous sommes les bat
rhône nous sommes un groupe d'ultras
versailles est souvent et versailles une
image un peu pompeuse alors que pelé
tour d'avoir un groupe d'ultras
totalement classique bien sûr comme tous
les groupes on a un local où on se
retrouve on prépare les tifos tout ça
les activités liées c'est le même depuis
le 17e siècle tout simplement nous a été
prêtée par le prieuré de versailles donc
c'est autre chose que les algeco d' de
l'olympique marseille
c'est pas joli
conte exclusivité pour cinq minutes foot
side la visite du local débattent trône
et voilà
bienvenue dans notre humble local de
supporteurs
voilà nous avons croquer la première
grande victoire historique du club 723
contre le fc compiègne le pape qui vient
féliciter les joueurs et le directeur
sportif arribart pas jean-luc un jean
pleutre
votre avis pierre sur cette vidéo c'est
les copains et copines octobre assez
raffiné et ses deux essais deux super
potes là qui font qu'ils font les sauts
prônent eux notamment les sopranos et là
là là ils ont été très très inspiré on
est dans le cliché on est dedans on est
dans l'humour l'humour un petit peu
vache mais là aussi où dans l'histoire
qui a une histoire avec un grand h ou
avec un petit h qui s'écrit en ce moment
à versailles avec la découverte
justement que versailles est une vie
sportive la mairie la mairie pouces et
on est plusieurs sections sportives à
pouvoir le le confirmer mais ils sont
bons ces mecs là ils sont bons yann ça
montre aussi que le fc versailles 78
finalement on en parle de partout en ce
moment et c'est à chaque fois qu'un
petit poucet arrive à passer des tours
et arrive à ce niveau de compétition on
en parle tout le temps et est donc bah
oui là versailles et c'est normal qu'on
en parle et et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut briller dans ces coupes
de france pour pouvoir avoir des encarts
dans l'équipe pour pouvoir être
interviewé pour enfin voila c'est ses
joueurs n'auront peut-être plus la
chance de pouvoir le revivre mais là ils
vivent une expérience unique et
l'expérience de leur vie
c'est le moment de gloire de versailles
julien cazarre qui est pas remis de ce
trio il ya sébastien thoen ya thomas
séraphine et julien cazarre qui
parodient d'habitude plutôt la ligue 1
on l'avait connu sur une autre chaîne à
la chaîne câblée
et qui ressemble à mon nom de famille
d'ailleurs mais on l'avait vu parodier
la ligue 1 où ils doublaient de manière
très drôle des scènes de ligue 1 et ses
sketches aussi sur la ligue 1 et là
c'est sûr versailles franchement c'est
une exposition de dingue pour pour ce
club il faut qu'ils profitent à fond de
cet engouement et et la vidéo est très
drôle il joue sur les codes il joue sur
les stéréotypes d'ailleurs les
supporters qu'on avait suivi avait joué
aussi sur sa en mettant des dépôts des
perruques un peu
en disant on espère que le roi soleil
est avec nous aujourd'hui voilà il
jouait sur les voyages histoire une
histoire d'air on adore ça jean qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette vidéo mais
c'est super c'est super c'est vrai
quelle somme il veut à peu près sûr sur
les réseaux m'étonne pas c'est frais
c'est un humour voilà petit humour qui
qui marque bien un petit peu
tout à fait non mais c'est bien parce
que justement ça vaut même pas la place
elle est en place les jeunes qui
justement les versailles et le snobisme
mais voilà donc j'en fais une belle
parodie moi je trouve ça je trouve ça
génial et qu'elle des années 90 des
inconnus quand même hein c'est vraiment
pile poil enfin moi ça nous met ça en
fait en pleine face on te dit pas si
mais oui on va finir par fermer cette
page un verre ça et parce qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé dans cette émission par
les pronostics les pronostics alors on
va y aller
je moi je vais je vais rester sur le 1 0
1 1 0 pour versailles et rendez vous
rendez vous au stade de france pierre
j'ai jamais dit que j'allais dire 2 0
pour nice pour être mêlé chez envie
d'autre chose j'ai vraiment bien être
chauvin donc tu y ont vu la vidéo qui
nous a
sacrément tirs au but de versailles
genre alors moi je joue veille mais
réaliste sportivement activement j'irai
3 1 pour nice 3-1 pour nice grégory 2 0
pour nice
super versailles rendez vous du coup
vous nous prenez la place du couple au
stade de france absolument suivre le dit
lui-même dit pas de bêtise à sera le 18
20 au mois de mai en tout cas alors le
match contre lille c'est donc programmée
le 1er mars prochain à nice en reviendra
évidemment sur ce match dans ce prochain
à si on parlait sport on passe à notre
page débats
[Musique]
alors on devait parler de tony yoka l'on
va parler tout de suite de grégory baugé
on n'aura malheureusement pas le temps
de parler d'eux ni aucun n'en parlera
dans une prochaine émission grégory
baugé qui vient d'être nommé au poste
d'entraîneur du sprint
alors il est de retour aux affaires
après avoir mis un terme à sa carrière
en janvier à 2020 les viennois grégory
baugé donc quadruple médaillé olympique
va devenir entraîneur de l'équipe
nationale du sprint à compter du mois de
mars il a été choisi par le nouveau
directeur du programme olympique florian
rousseau il aura pour objectif d'aider
les sprinters a glané des médailles aux
jeux olympiques de paris en 2024 il
entraînera donc les sportifs au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la question
sur ce thème grégory baugé de retour est
ce que c'est une bonne idée vous votez
oui
non unanime yann pour moi
on peut parler ainsi voulu
parce qu'il n'y a pas de débat
mais tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui quand on regarde l équipe
entraîneur de l'équipe de france
l'équipe des coachs il n'y avait pas de
grand nom
herman terrain clara sanchez s'était pas
l'aimer pas 7,7 rayonnant ce que greg
pourra avoir et du coup l'expérience que
greg à grégory baugé comme vous l'avez
dit c'est quatre médailles olympiques et
un titre pour lui et pour lui du coût
des déceptions mais surtout c'est quand
même neuf titres de champion du monde et
ça c'est une expérience sur lesquels les
gars vont pouvoir vont pouvoir s'appuyer
moi j'ai découvert un grégory baugé
depuis bientôt deux ans maintenant
entraîneur parce qu'il coache marie
patouiller qui est une athlète
handisport et qui a ramené mes de bronze
deux médailles de bronze d'ailleurs des
jeux paralympiques de tokyo et je pense
qu'il est très très bon
il y en avait eu un débat il ya quelques
mois et je suis ta faim et après ça
après sa retraite j'avais dit que pour
moi c'était là l'homme de la situation
donc maintenant qu'il est nommé je vais
pas avoir un discours qui va aller qui
va aller à l'envers je vais vraiment
rester là dessus je pense que je pense
que ça va être un vrai plus pour pour
les pour les gars parce que pour moi
sébastien vigier ou un ryan et la halle
se sont font partie du gratin et des
meilleurs sprinteurs mondiaux sébastien
était justement en phase de reconquête
puisqu'il y est revenue avec une
médaille des derniers championnats du
monde je crois qu'il a primé de bronze
sur la vitesse je suis plus sûr parce
que pour nous il n'ya que le médaille
accueillait qu'il ya que le maillot qui
comptent qui compte mais voilà sébastien
est en train de 2,2 de monter en
puissance et là je pense que ça va être
vraiment l'ingrédient qui qui va bien et
à dernière chose le timing est parfait
on est en 2022 pour les jo en 2024 c'est
cet idéal et les championnes grigorij de
cyclisme sur piste qui arrive en plus au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
je vais pas répéter ce qu'a dit adila il
a presque tout dit moi je trouve
l'association florian rousseau grégory
baugé très intéressante florian aussi on
avait eu l'occasion d'en parler on
présente plus aussi le palmarès qui lui
sera directeur du programme olympique je
trouve que d'avoir ce greg baugé et bien
entraîneurs du sprint c'est ça un duo
très intéressant
le palmarès il là il en plus
l'expérience d'entraîneur il ya de la
rappeler avec cette collaboration avec
marie patouiller qui en plus ça a été
une collaboration fructueuse et ses
médailles ramenées des jeux
paralympiques il est proche il connaît
bien le milieu et connaît les athlètes
en poste moi je pense que tous les
voyants sont au vert tout est réuni pour
qu'on puisse avoir une une belle
expérience et j'espère que on aura une
expérience de longue date depuis 2013 il
ya des entraîneurs qui sont succédé
parfois avec des gros échec sur sur ce
sprint on
on rappelle voilà l'expérience avec le
duo notamment avec clara sanchez et
c'était m herman ouais c'est ça qui
était donc voilà on espère une réussite
mais en tout cas pour moi tous les
voyants sont au vert pour qu'on ait une
réussite de ce point de vue là le genre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez bah moi
j'ai du jus on est tous d'accord il a
accroché quand même il ya un an est-ce
que c'est pas trop tôt bien alors il a
37 ans et la hanche et il ya un an non
intentionnelle du tout c'est hillary il
est est ce que c'est une force tout cas
si tout les voyants sont au vert il a
encore déjà ça peut être une force parce
qu'un an ça lui a permis de souffler de
reprendre de l'énergie et tous les
voyants sont au vert techniquement il
est bon et mentalement ce garçon-là a
connu la réussite et la défaite
donc on ne peut on ne peut jamais
reporter leur olympique je tiens pour
lui mais il a quand même il a k'un
plusieurs titres champion du monde est
hissé il ay laquelle il a quand même il
a quand même connu la réussite et il a
connu aussi la défaite donc au niveau la
préparation des sportifs on ne parle
jamais aussi bien de ce qu'on a vécu et
de ce qu'on connaît donc ça c'est très
important parce que souvent et je pense
que yann pourquoi le pouvoir le
confirmer ça se joue avec des détails et
c'est souvent c'est dans la tête que ça
se joue souvent le sport au niveau c'est
dans la tête on le sait est donc ce
garçon là pour moi à tous les voyants au
vert et on ne pouvait avoir
papa mieux pour moi que le vin qu'un
garçon comme grégory baugé dire
surveiller en face avec janot en disant
que que c'est un nom c'est un palmarès
et je pense que mentalement si je me
trompe pas sa fin de carrière a été un
petit peu délicate et je pense qu'il
arrive revanche à doha c'est pas la même
ilhama russe a remporté l'or au lancer
serré durant que de remporter lui à
titre individuel ou par équipe sur le
vélo mais on est une équipe qui plus est
à paris en 2024 vers les titres suprêmes
là pour le coup je pense qu'il a il a il
a effectivement le l'humeur le mental et
l'expérience qu'il faut pour l'épauler
arrivé pour les driver pour les driver
comme ça il a un gros caractère aussi
grégory baugé on l'a souvent un peu
décrié à pour ça ce que vous pensez que
ça va le faire ou pas avec avec rousseau
et c'est le duo parfait ils se
connaissent grégory
grégory ne demandait que ça à la
fédération que ce soit florian rousseau
qui soit l'entraîneur de l'équipe de
france depuis ils s'entendent comme cul
et chemise c'est une vraie une
vraie une vraie amitié et une très très
bonne relation ils ont eu le trac
confiance l'a enlevé l'un envers l'autre
grégory a eu ses meilleurs résultats en
tant que sportif quand gorin florian
rousseau était à la tête de l'équipe de
france donc le duo est pas joué par fait
c'est vraiment et de toute façon dès le
moment en plus et ça c'est que nous on
savait un
même si c'était pas officiel c'est que
des moments où france florian rousseau a
été nommé à la tête de la
préparation olympique on savait que
grégory allait arriver derrière c'était
une évidence après peut-être que
j'aurais pu refuser mais voilà c'était
sûr que la perche lui aurait été lancée
il a saisi cci vial puisqu'il représente
tous les deux de génération victorieuse
alors oui si grégory baugé n'a pas eu
cette médaille d'or olympique mais deux
générations qui ont marqué aussi leur
leur année en cyclisme et pourquoi pas
faire briller la prochaine génération
envie de parler de 1024 je trouve que la
belle histoire est à écrire et il ya un
groupe très jeune aussi à cette équipe
de france est quand même très jeunes et
ils ont besoin de cette expérience au
oui mais très jeune mais ce sont aussi
des athlètes qui y ont connu grégory en
tant que coéquipier ils ont fait des
séances d'entraînement ils ont ils l'ont
eue ils n'ont eu tous ils ont tous pu
performer et ils ont tous été à
l'entraînement avec lui je pense qu'il
ya une bonne relation et sincèrement
grégory entraîneur n'est pas du tout la
même personne que le grégory
compétiteurs et qu'il pouvait être il a
eu une évolution ces dernières années et
qui sait y ait une évolution ces
dernières années donc pour vous on va
reporter plein de médailles aux jo en
oui
oui oui oui oui si si si si je pense que
là il va y avoir un cap supplémentaire
et la différence qui alors après les
hollandais ont encore une seconde
d'avancé on a deux ans pour aller
chercher cette seconde et
et pour moi oui il ya possibilité il ya
et le match le match le match commence
voilà les matchs commencent mal le match
commence c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitat
très rapidement la grille dire que la
finale de la coupe de france c'est le 8
mai pas le 18 mai j'étais à dix jours
près sur la bonne la bonne vous
pardonnera si versailles est en finale
en tout cas alors c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude du cou par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
de luis fernandez ancien joueur de
l'équipe de france et du psg et joueur
au psg et entraîneur au psg le succès
n'a pas besoin d'explications l'échec
nahd mais pas de justification je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78 est allé versailles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]